also in welchen vernünftigen seiten am
screenshots davon gepostet dass es sehr
sehr viele ip michael schumacher seiten
schon gibt warum ich habe miniatur
hätten ihre freunde herzlich willkommen
zurück zu minecraft hero was mir
aufgefallen als ich nehme die folge
gerade direkt im anschluss zu der folge
gestern vom dritten auf weil einfach so
das prinzip war vor prozess wegen
hamburg und so et cetera was mir
aufgefallen ich habe ihm oft
fallengelassen und die werde ich jetzt
erst mal ausmachen weil da bestimmt
wieder ein bisschen was gespannt wer
nämlich direkt hier abgeschossen
von irgendwo ich habe keine ahnung von
gutachtern heftiges skelett wieder sonst
hätte ich nicht so viel zufällig denn so
viel schaden sag mal ich muss langsam
auch mal eine rüstung hier echt mal
verzaubern wandel der ist gleich so
heftig ich muss dir echt und unecht war
verzaubert bisher nur stärke und ich
habe zwar vor du bist genau wie soll ich
denn so viel schaden bekommen also das
nächste was auf jeden fall verzaubert
wird ist die rüstung auf an breaking wo
wir haben ja echt items pura das heftig
diese sounds in mega laut man ganz kurz
durchschlagen de ist nix mehr so die
ganzen sachen überlegen brauche ich
ähnlich habe ich jetzt als im inventar
die die pleite getrieben die rüstungen
das hier stelle ich auch schon mal drin
habe ich dann ja die stecken sich okay
gut ich bin alle sachen schon mal so ein
bisschen immer mal hier rüber ich werde
gleich schlafen gehen ja sofort zu ihr
kommt da hat darauf die ganze bögen und
so schmeiße ich mal müll hier bei
cash.life bilden brach ich eh nicht rein
da rein da habe ich genug knochen dass
das dass das kam sondern good case
ich habe zwar lange gesessen aber das
sind ich werde bald echt mal alle sachen
wegschmeißen die ich nicht brauche also
dass hier werde ich jetzt erstmal
behalten aber naja ein obsidian ja
kommen lasse ich erst mal drin kann ja
das ist noch mal brauchen werde
ich mache dem opfern erst mal gar nicht
braucht endlich ein bisschen mehr um
eine komplette rüstung auf links zu
verzaubern auf an breaking zu verzaubern
18 level kostet allein der helm ja okay
da war ich locker 60 level oder so ja
gut ich werde jetzt mal mehr oder
weniger mein umzug plant ich geld erst
mal ganz kurz kennen
da wäre ich dann schild hinstellen und
dann werde ich mein komplettes haus
circa ich sehe wieder so üblich aus in
der fei scam weil es liegt nicht an der
beleuchtung sind das liegt einfach in
den einstellungen der face käm ich mach
das mal ganz kurz
so ist jetzt ein bisschen über hält
vielleicht aber es ist auf jeden fall
besser aus
guckt mal an die wada geht die sonne auf
sonst würd mich die sonne da nicht an
möchten
juhu schöner sonnenaufgang mit luca hast
du die karte brauch ich eh nicht gemacht
jetzt ich will unsere stadt zieht von
rechts schön aus ich finde statt rot
immer noch am schönsten das muss ich
echt offen zugeben aber unsere stadt
finde ich entwickelt sich und das den
heftigen schritten mit dem wegen und so
durch zb auf und da werde ich dann auch
noch mal ein bisschen was ich als machen
wenn ich erst mal selbst mein standort
habe
was war das denn jetzt kann man einen
bogen austesten tod zwei schüsse geil
aber was ist denn da explodiert wartet
es manchmal ganz kurz wissen nicht dass
da irgendwas passiert ist nichts
passiert ist vielleicht einfach nur so
irgendwas explodiert aber ich weiß ja
nicht was das ist ja das komische gerade
mein blick sword ist auch gleich kaputt
egal da machen wir neues so auch jetzt
bin ich wieder okay jetzt kommt das hier
das ist glaube ich sogar mit teuersten
oder schafft das mit 22 level an
breaking ja so jetzt in der zwischenzeit
wo dann wieder gleich ein paar sachen
spawnen ich mache erst mal ganz kurz
nach meinem big scotty dran kaputt
das ist mir dann gleich schon mal direkt
ein neues mache ich frag mich immer noch
wann endlich mal wieder hier ein
mexikaner entfallen lässt das war
megageil
weil dann kann ich mir hier wieder so
ein paar sachen machen für etwas
bescheidener
so kann ich dir nicht aufsammeln okay
gut ein paar sachen für die nächste
rüstung so beckmann
wenn diese doofen verzauberung gib mir
mein linkes wort
aber das macht ja eigentlich nur um das
ich nichts sehe oder blind nist das ist
ja eigentlich nichts schlimmes und 102
level das heißt muss ist noch die ganze
zeit durchmachen erliegt man nix potter
oder ist das einfach okay gut dachte
zweck kaputt gegangen acom ohne witzig
bahnsteige gleich die ganze zeit mit
meinem änderten sporteinsätze mir die
haltbarkeit jetzt relativ egal
okay okay es wird mir abgezogen sehr
schön
klasse rhein-main energy water dieses
verdammte miststück in der mod falle
gibt es mir nicht wieder ich bitte euch
das doch langweilig na gut wir können
das thema auspacken
was kann man dann reden wir können mal
über michael schumacher reden und nicht
den fall an sich sondern die ganzen
scheiß halten die da schon machen
gemacht wurden
ich gehe einfach mal in facebook und
sehe schon dass screenshots gegen welche
seiten gepostet haben also irgendwelchem
vernünftigen seiten am screenshots davon
gepostet dass es sehr sehr viele
michael schumacher seiten schon gibt
warum ich hab miniatur herz ist geil
warum macht man miniatur herzen er ist
nicht tot er kämpft um sein leben und es
ist sogar ein besserer zustand
mittlerweile und das ist ja schön daran
sollten wir uns erfreuen
und da machen leute einfach nur so sei
die seite einfach nur um likes zu
generieren das ist doch einfach scheiße
so was mach jetzt mal ganz kurz eben die
monster falle aus damit dass ich noch
mehr sparen damit sie nicht mein schwert
dann in die weitergeben oder so wie das
mmx wort kann irgendwie nicht kaputt
gehen das ist einfach hier und geht
nicht kaputt
wieviel leben hat dieses eine skelett
noch nicht mal gar nichts gar nicht mal
so viel wie vergiftet und ich hab nix
wort was ihn annehmen kann natal die
kerker ich war nicht lang vergiftet das
tut ja also ich verstehe so was nicht
warum macht man doch im exportland
ich habe meinen und jetzt gepanscht
meine lieben jetzt ist wieder weg sehr
schön da liegt es
warum macht man solche seiten ich meine
michael schumacher war damals mein
größtes vorbild jetzt mal ohne scheiß
weil er halt einfach weiß nicht aber
halt damit die beste formel-1-fahrer hat
sein comeback da gemacht nicht um geld
zu generieren
weil er hält den sport vermisst hat und
ich finde wir sollten seine personen
unterstützt und die familie nicht seiten
machen wie michael michael schumacher
ich finde sowas einfach nur herzlos und
respektlos ist einfach nur scheiße weiß
nicht ich kapiere sowas nicht wusste
schwert hin
jetzt haben die mir mein vater mein weg
sword abgezogen
geborgenheit
sie treffen können
ach mein bogen haben so auch jannis
schön kann sein dass immer welche treffe
das einfach die sachen abzieht und
dieses blöde klackert erregte auch auf
mein handy an wieder vibriert alle
scheiße hier aber es ist nur noch dieses
eine und es hat ein little giants wort
fallen lassen
living metal dance bot das ist schön
das wäre cool wenn ich jetzt die ganzen
sachen schlager mit dem linken magic
sword das eher cool wenn ich die ganze
sache die ich jetzt hier so habe dass
ich dir einfach irgendwie spenden könnte
dass sich dann dafür irgendwie weil sie
nicht dass ich dafür dann irgendwie
erfahrung bekomme das irgendwie geil
dass ich quasi also da sind zwar schon
ich weiß es nicht die erzeugung davon
ich runter nehmen kann
acom das regt mich jetzt so auf als
machen wenn ich das einmal panzer
verliert ist zwei leben mit meinem und
jetzt hat mein schwert in der hand doch
nicht das ist doch es ist auch witzlos
es generiert sogar neu alter ok ok gar
nicht das nicht irgendwie verzaubern
oder so kann ich das nicht vergiften
es ist scheiße jetzt nicht die ganze
zeit in diesem scheiss blätter geht
nicht glaube ich man noch mal wieder ein
paar sachen meteorit axt brauche ich
eigentlich auch nicht egal
ich brauche ich nicht immer ein hör auf
zu schießen ich lebe hat der 33 ich
brauche ich so einen export wieder
transport des world wide format die
skype ich weiß ich jetzt eigentlich auch
mal ganz gut
ok meines geistes weg und er hat ein
leben verloren
ok freunde ich mache mir jetzt ich
sollte erst mal ganz kurz so miniatur
herz kommt darin die kiste ich könnte
theoretisch schon drei von diesen
kanistern machen ich meine die apps
machen ist nicht sonderlich schwer aber
dieses aluminium wir müssen uns erstmal
auf eine aluminium suche begeben so dass
obsidian packe ich mal hier mit rein
warum ist das hier da drin war
ich glaube ich habe nie irgendetwas
sortiert das ist so traurig scheiße mann
ich brauch recht einfach mal so ich
mache einfach eine kiste mit sachen die
ich nie
es ist kacke dass ich einfach keine
ordnung hier drin und das ist das was am
wenigsten spaß macht der mannschaft
dieses kisten sortieren man was ist wenn
ich dieses wenn ich die das dingsbums da
einfach mit ihr teilen ihr ab schieße
habe ich nicht aluminium o'barry
aluminium nuggets
ich glaub ich glaube ich glaube ich
brauche ein paar von diesen aluminium
nuggets dings machen zu können
aluminium machen zu können ob ich noch
mehr aluminium o'barry ich wusste gleich
dass aluminium hier so wertvoll ist das
ist ja mehr oder weniger das was ich
jetzt am meisten benötigen was ich
gucken wollte war ob ich das teil nicht
mit dem ball irgendwie er mit uns
abschließen kann habe ich überhaupt hier
hab ich so ich dachte immer ganz kurz
mit meiner in meinem revolver hin
geil gar nichts verloren
ich find das echt cool
ich hab dann voll wir nicht nein
verdammt so ihr kommt daran eine neue
schaufel wollte ich mir noch machen eine
klare sprache welche diamanten und 2x
nein ich nehme gerade auf ich nehme
gerade auf mein gott wenn ich das sage
ich nehme oft kommen auch wenn ich den
leuten hier sage den meinen
familienmitgliedern wenn ich dann nicht
so eine schaufel macht wenn ich dir sage
ich nehme auf dann kommen sie trotzdem
ran ich versteh's nicht ich verstehe es
wirklich nicht wenn ihren haushalt seit
wird das genehmigt wird dann sehe ich
direkt zu euch so wat die sticks kommen
da rein bux bux brauche ich nicht
bridge pärchen blabla kommen machen ein
geschenk des ponys mein körper oder mit
zum bak michael bay
wie setze ich mich einfach an oder
schreibt ihr nicht dass es von mir kommt
nicht rein
was das denn ach deswegen verkleinerte
hier meinten
ach so ja auch gut wir stellen nicht so
lustig naja komme ich zu jung
es muss nicht mehr so ich wollte mir ein
erstmalig ich muss jetzt wirklich
erstmal hier ein schild machen damit ich
da festhalten kann dass das mein
grundstück wird jetzt die lücke klafft
also alle dinge die hier stehen sind
meine und abbauen ist nicht regelkonform
so darstellen jetzt auch eine fackel rum
das ist auch jeder sieht dann werde ich
andere ist jetzt auch über packen so die
schilder stehen daten erst mal kommen
ein remix water mit den wenigstens in
dieser folge hat dieses heftige ding
töten können so stix irgendeinen scheiß
dixon das unglaubliche taktik
reisen und diamanten so ich mache mir
erst mal direkt zwei weil ich ja hier
der bar bin zwei handels zwei allem
wixforth sollten solche irgendwie
verzaubern ein quatsch es geht doch so
oder
durch geht's einfach immer dahin immer
nach vorne immer weiter hallo
ach so hirsch gut muss das zweite da und
das ist heute und jetzt wechselt beiden
immer ich weiß nicht 31 29 28 27 26 25
24 ich guck mal ganz gut wieder wo tag
und nacht ist ich verliere echt ein
bisschen jetzt habe ich sogar länger
bleiben ist wenn ich die ganze zeit
hintereinander mache 26er wieso kriegt
kein schaden
kisdorf 25 24 23 jeder kriegt keinen
schaden
ich muss echt immer ich will ich will
einfach nur ein heftigen der irgend was
hat er denn auf dem rücken der den
heftigen panzer auf dem rücken
ich will gar nicht wissen was der mir
viel schaden machen würde wenn ich ihn
so hätte das ist ein richtig richtig
heftiger ob einfach oder ich hab einfach
die falsche taktik um daran zu gehen und
es ist nicht so dass wir eine blühende
blumen schenken müsste
und wer direkt freundlich hier das
könnte auch sein dass gegen die sonne
sondern special movement hat oder so 17
auch leistet bekommt er gar keinen
schaden mehr als 60
das ist kacke ich verbringe jetzt die
ganze folge vor diesem scheiß mob ihr
aber gut das bin ich kein schuldig wenn
ich hier die chance in seiner monster
falle mache dann ist es normal dass man
das auch damit vernünftig macht hallo
diese treffen können hey komm
sorry leute dass sich die folge jetzt so
scheiße verschwindet jetzt wird es
wieder 500 milliarden des lecks geben
auch conny das so langweilig was du
machst
wie gesagt es bereite mich schon seit 10
20 folgen zeigt auf den krieg vor hab
gesagt dass ich das machen werde
er wollte dass das mache deswegen mache
ich wenn das nicht 1000 level
erfahrungen werden dann werde ich aber
böse
herr
bin ich 4 3 2 1 und jetzt der letzte
schlag 1 immer noch alles okay auch gut
was hab ich jetzt bekommen ich hatte die
ganze zeit gar nicht mehr james bond
habe ich meinen zurückbekommen mein gott
das war alles ich wusste dass ich
enttäuscht werde ich wusste es einfach
wieso wusste ich es so du kommst da rein
einem bleifuß lud die macht kommen
wissenschaftler drei mannschaften habe
ich eh dabei brauche ich nur hohle bla
bla bla bla richtig freuen ich dachte
ich vielleicht doch das ändert 1 vortag
taliban eine kiste wetter braucht das
nochmal falls mainz kaputt geht und
jetzt wie kaputt das alles ist einfach
scheiße mann
oha das ist krass boah mein handy also
jetzt kommt wieder dieser trick hier
dass ich alles runter nehmen muss außer
an breaking dann kann man das nämlich
leichter repair dann packe ich an
breaking wieder drauf und protection so
jetzt nehme ich hier wieder alles runter
sollte oft aber auch nicht was drauf
repair kann ich nicht weiß ich muss
sollte ich muss an breaking drauf machen
reparieren
das kommt an breaking 3 und ein brötchen
1 wie heißt den sold at 2 26
wenn jedoch jetzt geht's ich verstehe
diese kg nicht so repair kost 6 ok jetzt
habe ich nur noch zweifel auch gut aber
hier ist an breaking drauf an breaking
und soll das ehepaar drauf solche
einzeltäter darauf auch gut luca park
einfach sollte herunter alle haben sich
jetzt bestimmt schon gegen kopf
geschlagen an sich gedacht so luca auch
du psa macht er einfach kein salter
darauf der blöde vollidiot so hier auch
nochmal protection runter holt etwa
drauf jetzt habe ich noch ein level gut
sollte das alter an breaking 3 an
breaking 1 und ich hab noch ein level
gut die folge ist wieder top ich meine
freunde ich hab's noch nicht hingekriegt
irgendwelche sachen drüber zu tragen
ich packe noch eben ein paar sachen rein
die ich nicht brauche das hier sind so
sachen die ich immer im inventar hat
mittlerweile die spiegel die rucksäcke
das brauche ich nicht eine zweite
staffel brauch erst mal nicht was zu
essen vielleicht immer so ein bisschen
tricksen ein schild broich auch nicht
dass man hier in jeans und auch und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen essen über
mal dabei hier ist einfach darin dass es
auch gut
da sieht man wieder wie toll ich
sortieren kann wo man lieben freunden
will ich sagen die sachen die ich machen
wollte habe ich jetzt mehr oder weniger
geschafft in den nächsten folgen werde
ich dann mein umzug hierhin planen dass
wir denke ich richtig cool man rüstung
und so stehen schon hier dass man wenn
irgendwer so hoch ist wie das cloud dann
boxee dem aufs maul und dann würde ich
sagen wir sehen uns in der nächsten
folge wieder wenn es euch gefallen hat
will ich mich definitiv über einen
daumen hoch freuen und dann schau